ordering stuff online is usually pretty
simple returning it
not so much
[Music]
the returns process is complicated for
retailers too online shopping booms
during the pandemic which caused online
returns to Skyrocket too last year
people returned about 212 billion
dollars worth of merchandise bought
online and to handle all that demand
some retailers have started charging
consumers for returns or prohibiting
them entirely now some companies are
trying something new and you don't need
a box a label or any of this stuff you
don't even need to leave your home now
companies like Walmart doordash and
others are racing to make returns for
you and that's because there's a lot of
money on the line
great they're closed whenever you return
something retailers pay up to 39 of that
item's cost just to process the return
in the past an online return typically
played out like this the customer takes
the item they want to return to the
shipper or the shipper picks it up the
shipper transports the package to return
centers where the item is inspected and
sorted retailers alert you when the item
has been received and you get a refund
or store credit some items get restocked
while damaged items get disposed of or
refurbished home pickup streamline this
process to be potentially cheaper for
retailers and better for customers I
wanted to better understand what the new
world of returns could look like so I
went for a ride with the last mile
Logistics startup return mates hey how's
it going
I'm well I'm well return mates usually
charges Shoppers if you to have gig
workers pick up their packages but now
the company is part of a growing network
of Partners enabling return pickups
without charging the Shopper anything
completely removing one step of the
traditional process for customers so
we're heading to Brooklyn uh we use a
app called on fleet and that's where we
will see our task where we are supposed
to pick up and drop off packages the app
will redirect me to the GPS and let me
know where to go customers simply
request a home pickup without needing to
package anything that request is added
to a driver's route the driver pulls up
picks up the item outside or rings your
doorbell to hand it off I would take the
photo of the package okay and I would
scan the barcode that's all once all the
pickups are made drivers head back to
the warehouse where items are sorted and
grouped to be set back to retailers for
restocking but there are some
limitations it's only available in some
big cities in the U.S and the CEO of
return mate says that for now the main
item the company picks up is apparel we
typically put a restriction of 40 pounds
on items the phrase we use is it has to
fit in the trunk of a Prius so no TV
pickups just yet Amina Ali is the CEO of
opturo the company provides big Brands
like the Gap Best Buy and Ikea with
software for online returns it's now
expanding its software to companies
looking to offer pickup services
including return mates we have a lot of
people contacting us who want to be
pickup Partners some big some small for
retailers like Tucker Nook modernizing
return Logistics can have benefits it
gets it back to our warehouse faster and
allows us to resell it that much faster
instead of dealing with six different
customer returns in six separate boxes a
courier can group those items into one
package making them easier to store and
transport consumers welcome a change to
the return process we're all used to
most online Shoppers say they'd feel
more comfortable shopping with retailers
offering complimentary front door
pickups survey data shows that most
Shoppers wish making an online return
was easier and don't want to pay for
online returns all the value of getting
a return back faster a cruise to the
retailer that's Christian Piller a
supply chain expert and co-founder of
inventory management startup pollen
there's no reason to charge the consumer
another subscription fee or per package
pickup fee optoro says luxury retailers
selling pricey items are more likely to
offer home pickups as a free option
since they may have less overall
inventory and more to lose when
expensive items get stuck in the return
process retailers can still charge you
to offset their shipping costs or try to
just discourage you from sending
something back physically taking an item
back to a brick and mortar store is
annoying but it's simple for both
retailers and consumers when you return
something online a lot more has to
happen on the back end to transport
verify and resell an item this is why a
lot of stores might benefit from being
able to control how quickly they get an
item back but
the process will require some upfront
investment and most likely significant
efficient changes to a company's
existing workflow smaller retailers with
fewer customers might not be as
incentivized as big retailers grappling
with thousands of returns and some may
still believe that customers are
satisfied with their existing returns
process for us the faster a retailer has
eyes on our return the faster we can get
a refund and when we aren't so busy
trying to figure out how to return all
this stuff we have more time back to
order more stuff online
please